-Our next guest is
a Grammy-nominated
singer and songwriter
whose new single, "brrr,"
is out now.
Please welcome to the show,
Kim Petras, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show, Kim!
Are you well?
-Thank you!
Yeah, I'm so excited to be here.
Thanks for having me.
-I was so excited to see you
on Saturday.
You made your "SNL" debut,
and I think it's always
a little nerve-wracking
to appear on "SNL"
for the first time.
You had sort of
a higher bar of entry
than anyone I've ever seen,
because you were sort of
hiding under Sam's dress
and then revealed.
-Yeah.
It was a moment, for sure.
I was under there for
a long time.
-Yeah.
-So it was very well-rehearsed.
-And I've got to imagine it's
not super cool and breezy.
-Not at all.
-Yeah.
-Nope. It was very hot.
I was, like, sweating.
And also, Sam was moving a lot,
so I was like --
I don't know if you guys know
the little Kim dance,
but I was like --
[ Laughter ]
You know, I was just
trying to, like --
because I had to hold it,
because otherwise,
I would get these crazy flyaways
and everyone would be like,
"She had flyaways last time,"
so it was just like, yeah.
I just had to dodge with Sam.
But worth it.
-Yeah.
-Someone on TikTok predicted it,
but other than that,
it was a surprise.
-Someone predicted you'd
be under the dress?
-Yes, there's a TikTok
that's like,
"Oh, I bet she's
under the dress,"
and then they all
scream and jump up.
It's good!
-You also got to go to
the afterparty.
Here you are with the
wonderful host of the evening,
Aubrey Plaza.
-Aubrey! I'm such a fan.
-This is a big deal. Madonna!
Now, had you ever met
Madonna before?
-Um, I met her briefly
at Pride years ago,
but not like this.
We talked and I was, like,
really obliterated drunk
and I was just like,
"You're my queen!"
And it was the afterparty
and she just showed up.
I'm sure she thinks I'm crazy.
But yeah, I was like,
"You are the blueprint
for everybody
and you need to know this!
And this album means
so much to me
and 'Confessions
on the Dance Floor'
was the best album ever."
I was just, like, going ham,
and then she was like,
"You want to take a picture?"
She was like, "Mm-hmm."
-By the way,
there's nothing better
than when a celebrity
clocks the moment
and is like, "I'm gonna
ask you to stop talking."
-Yeah.
-And we're gonna get
the picture that you're gonna
want from this moment, right?
-Yeah, no, totally, because
I wouldn't have gotten one.
I was like, way too scared.
-Is this the moment after?
-Yes! [ Laughs ]
-She was just like, it felt like
she was my only friend
when I was a kid.
I listened to her music!
It went on for, like,
10 minutes.
I was crying my makeup off.
-Oh, my God. What a night.
First you're under a dress,
then you meet Madonna.
There's a lot going on.
-It's a Tuesday for me.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Yeah.
-I think you and I live
very different lives.
Another difference,
I've never been nominated
for a Grammy.
You got nominated for
a Grammy this year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What was the moment like
where you got to find out?
-My team yelled at me
from downstairs
and just, like,
came into my room
and I was just, like,
getting ready and I was like,
"What?" and yeah,
they were just like,
"You're nominated for a Grammy,"
and we all started
crying and jumping
and doing the things you do,
so yeah, it's crazy.
I can't believe it.
-Seems like you've had
a lot of good cries recently.
I think it's a very nice sign.
-Yeah, I cry a lot.
-Yeah, that's alright.
I men, if you're crying for
getting nominated for a Grammy,
like, let the tears flow, right?
-Yeah, for sure.
-Yeah.
-Good cries. Good cries.
-You and Sam, you got nominated
for the song that was your duet,
and you also set sort of a --
It was a historical precedent
for LGBTQ representation
at the Grammys, so
congratulations on that as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, guys.
Yeah, I mean, it's so crazy.
I feel like gay clubs raised me
and pop music.
No one loves pop music
more than gay clubs,
and honestly, I owe everything
I have to the gays in Bushwick.
You guys, honestly, I used to
perform on tables in bars
and whatever,
and now I'm nominated
for a Grammy.
It's so crazy,
because those were always
the places where I just, like,
felt like I belonged in there,
where like, pop music
and fun music is celebrated
like it has won
a bunch of Grammys.
So it's crazy that Sam and I
kind of did this club song
and it got nominated
for a Grammy.
And it's a very gay song,
so thank you, Grammys.
I really appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sam must be an incredible
person to collaborate with,
but I also a video of you
singing with your dog.
-Yeah.
-Your dog Karl, is that right?
-Karl, "Carl" with a K.
-Okay, Karl with a K.
And now we have a video of you
singing and Karl joining you.
Did this happen naturally
the first time?
Did Karl just start singing
along with you?
-Yeah, it kind of
happened right away.
Whenever I warm up,
he sits next to me,
on the chair next to me
and sings with me,
and he's really good.
He's getting better,
and I'm --
-But this isn't a --
You didn't go to
the pet store and say,
"Obviously, I'd love a dog
that could sing."
-No, of course I didn't.
-Okay, okay. Gotcha.
-Yeah, and I have
two other dogs,
so I was not expecting
such a brilliant voice
to come out of that guy.
-Do the other dogs kind of
think Karl's a lot?
Are they like, ugh?
-Yeah.
They're like,
"There he goes again.
All the attention."
They're mad in the corner.
-Let's see the
attention-grabbing
Karl the dog.
-[ Singing scales ]
-[ Howling in tune ]
-[ Laughs ] Aww.
-[ Singing scales ]
-[ Howling ]
[ Laughing ]
-Pretty amazing!
[ Applause ]
Pretty impressive.
-That's Karl.
He's a star.
Stealing my shine.
Stop it, Karl!
-This is a true story.
You are a huge fan of our other
guest tonight, Hilary Duff.
-Yes.
-What is your history
with Hilary Duff as a fan?
-Well, "Metamorphosis"
shaped me as a person.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, honestly,
"Lizzie McGuire"
was like, my life
when I was a kid.
I'm obsessed with her.
I'm obsessed with her concerts,
and I was like,
shrieking and freaking out
when I just met her backstage.
It's been so crazy
meeting all these legends,
and I just, like,
"Okay, here we go.
Just cry again, freak out,
you know."
But yeah, she just, like,
is so iconic,
and her music is so good.
And she really doesn't get
the credit that she deserves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know?
-Let's get her out here
and fix that.
-Pop star.
-I'm very happy about this
and I want to thank you
for sticking around.
You're gonna do your new song,
"Brrr."
Am I saying that...?
Is that a good...?
That's alright? I can...?
-Yeah, no. That's good.
It's not [Rolling R's] "Brrrrr."
-Okay, good.
-Yeah.
-It's "brr"? Alright, great.
Thank you very much.
And you've also had
a song called "Icy."
Is this sort of winter theme
something that is true to you?
-Yeah, I mean, I'm from Germany,
so it's cold there.
And I just feel like
the whole kind of like,
industrial feel of Germany
just offers itself to ice.
So all my fans keep making memes
of, like, Elsa twerking,
and I really appreciate it.
-Alright, great.
-That's honestly what
I want to give, you know?
A video of Elsa twerking.
So yeah, they're connected.
I have an ice block in my show,
so yeah.
More ice songs.
-There you go. More ice songs.
Well, I think probably you were
thinking about that ice block
when you were under Sam's dress.
You were like,
could have used that today.
-I could have really
used that then.
It wasn't there.
-Your fans have an album
to look forward to.
Tour as well? Are you gonna go
on the road in 2023?
-Yes, summer. So excited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, and it's been awhile.
It was like, before the pandemic
that I toured last.
-Oh, well, they'll be very, very
happy to see you.
-Thank God. Thank God.
-Alright.
I'm very excited to see you
in a few minutes.
You guys, that's Kim Petras.
Give it up!
We'll be right back with
her debut TV performance
of her new single, "Brrr."
-Brr!
-Brr! [Rolling R's]